Marvel's Black Widow' fills in Natasha Romanoff's
backstory — and along the way, it sets up
plenty of juicy possibilities for the future
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
The post-credits sequence in particular ties
together the stories of Black Widow, Avengers:
Endgame, The Falcon and the Winter Soldier,
and even the upcoming Hawkeye series, paving
the way for a seriously involved small-screen
situation within the MCU.
Black Widow is set after the events of 2016's
Captain America: Civil War and prior to those
of 2018's Avengers: Infinity War, but the
film's post-credits scene takes viewers to
an entirely different section of the MCU’s
timeline.
After the credits roll, the extra scene of
the new film jumps forward in time to the
world after Avengers: Endgame, focusing on
Nat's sister figure Yelena Belova in Ohio.
She's mourning Nat, who gave her life to secure
the Soul Stone on Vormir during the time heist
event in Endgame.
While Yelena is standing in front of Nat's
grave, a woman approaches her.
You recognize her, right?
“Valentina Allegra de la Fontaine, actually
it’s the Contessa Valentina Allegra de la
Fontaine”
You may also know her as Madame Hydra.
Additionally, you know her as the woman who
recruited John Walker to her cause in The
Falcon and the Winter Soldier.
“It’s hard, but I don’t like to repeat
myself so you can just call me Val, but don’t
call me Val, just keep it in your head.”
Valentina is looking to set Yelena on an ill-advised
revenge tour, which could shake the MCU.
Variety confirmed back in December 2020 that
Florence Pugh is set to reprise her role in
the upcoming Hawkeye TV show, starring Jeremy
Renner as Clint Barton and MCU newcomer Hailee
Steinfeld as Kate Bishop, Clint's protégé.
Based on what Val says to Yelena in the post-credits
sequence of "Black Widow," it seems likely
that she won't be showing up to help our heroes.
After Yelena chides Val for interrupting her
during her vacation, Val gets straight to
the point.
Before handing Yelena a tablet showing a photo
of Clint Barton, the Contessa says,
"Maybe you'd like a shot at the man responsible
for your sister's death.
Kind of a cutie, don't you think?"
It's certainly a bit of a stretch to call
Clint "responsible" for Natasha's death — they
both did everything they could to sacrifice
themselves on that mountain top — but The
Contessa isn't known for being a straight-shooter.
We can infer from this interaction that Yelena
has come to work for the Contessa, much like
John Walker did at the end of "The Falcon
and the Winter Soldier."
It seems Madame Hydra is amassing a team of
killers much like General Dreykov's Black
Widows.
A new power player is already taking his place
in the MCU espionage world, and she might
even have something to do with the Secret
Invasion.
Julia Louis-Dreyfus' appearance in the "Black
Widow" post-credits scene was definitely unexpected,
but it wasn't quite as surprising as it was
originally supposed to be.
Before the COVID-19 pandemic hit in early
2020, Louis-Dreyfus was set to join the MCU
during the post-credits scene of Black Widow,
but we all know what happened in 2020, so…
goodbye original MCU plans!
After re-shuffling the order a bit, Valentina
made her debut on The Falcon and the Winter
Soldier.
You can watch Julia Louis-Dreyfus in both
Black Widow and The Falcon and the Winter
Soldier on Disney+ — it’s an extra $29.99
for the movie, the series is no additional
charge to your monthly subscription.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don’t miss a single one.